Greg Olson had four choices technically
he could have selected the Seahawks the
bills or Washington or Fox he decides to
go to Seattle and join forces with Pete
Carroll Russell Wilson and company
another weapon for Russell Wilson and
look Chris last year Wilt dis Lee was
doing well at tight end to a torn ACL
against the was the Browns were a week
before that and then Jacob Hollister was
okay not spectacular but good enough
yeah that's now Greg Olson 35 years old
you know I don't know what he's got left
in the tank and the thing about father
time is he will kick your butt suddenly
and without warning but I kind of liked
the idea of Greg Olson squeezing out one
more year with a franchise quarterback
in Russell Wilson he's accustomed to
playing with a franchise quarterback in
Cam Newton and this gives Wilson
somebody he can throw the ball to if
Wilson is is adamant as he seemed to be
when we saw him a couple of weeks ago at
the Super Bowl about maybe trying to put
the pedal to the metal and move things
along and and and use his ability to
create not just with his feet but with
his arm yeah well you know and tight end
the the Seattle Seahawks and the Russell
Wilson era and Pete Carroll they valued
that position they have and you know
Greg Olson yeah he's not the player he
was five and six years ago but he is
still good he is I mean just when I
watched him this year and he's had he
know healthy you know he's still capable
of getting open in the pass game and
making plays that way and he's still a
viable blocker I mean he's not a killer
at the end of the line of scrimmage it's
not like it's George Kittel but it's
still good so you're getting everything
as far as what the Seattle Seahawks want
you know they're a balanced football
team that errors and kind of run first
yeah like we've heard Russell say we
want them to change a little bit but
Olson dependable it's a huge position
for them my only thing I would say to
Seattle I love the signing and I think
Greg Olson was really smart to go there
I mean anyway if you want to be a part
of a team that's got a chance to go to
the Super Bowl and put up good stats
maybe extend your career I think Seattle
was the right place but I do think
Seattle's also with his injury history
just the last few years they got
assigned a few other tight ends too for
the Justin case plan because he is at
that age of his career where things are
you know starting to fall apart a little
bit yeah we don't know where will this
Liz and his rehab from the ACL tear but
Russell Wilson had
affinity for dis li not just what he
does on the field but what he brings to
the locker room etc Hollister again good
enough now Seahawks fans wish it would
have been a couple more inches better at
the goal line in week 17 the last game
of the regular season no the Seahawks
would have won the division and the
49ers would have been relegated to the
number five seed but you know it's look
I like it because we don't see the
Seahawks typically do this they did the
trade for Jimmy Graham that never really
worked because I don't know they
expected him to show up in block are you
kidding me that's not what he does and
then they were frustrated when he didn't
block that's not what he does that's not
who you traded for so I think this time
around they go into it with the
understanding of who they're getting
what they're getting what the what the
abilities are what the limitations are
and and look to get the guy it brings
leadership instantly that's right the
locker room is going to respect him and
he gets a chance to chase a championship
you know of the three teams that he was
considering Chris the Seahawks are the
ones best positioned to win a Super Bowl
yeah that's right I mean you know it was
you know Seattle Buffalo in Washington
right that's the three that it came down
to and you know I did like the Buffalo
prospects there I think that is a tall a
team and offense that knows how to use
the tight end as well but you're right I
mean come on at the end of the day the
Seattle Seahawks were inches away from
being first-round bye and who knows
where that discussion goes if they do
get that touchdown or first down or
anything like that and the other thing
I'll say to Mike about is purely X's and
O's and football the thing I like about
it here is well yeah they run the ball
we know that but they got to freaky guys
on the edge right now and we spent some
time with one of those freaks at the
Super Bowl I mean DK Metcalf is he's a
budding superstar you know I wouldn't be
shocked if we came back here next year
at this time of the year and we go away
DK Metcalfe's one of the three or four
best receivers in football and then with
him lock it on the outside now you have
a guy like Olson to work the middle of
the field to who's a big target
Wilson sometime a little reluctant to
throw the ball
in the middle of the field because of
his lack of height and I don't know if
he always sees clearly but to have a big
target like this will encourage that and
I think make them a lot harder to defend
in their pass offense yeah
I agree with him and I think that you
know if this team wants to get back to
the Super Bowl and there is that urgency
that is beginning to creep out in
Russell Wilson he's eight years into his
career he's got one Super Bowl win
another Super Bowl appearance you have
to address your areas of need and you
have to show a willingness to go out and
be aggressive and maybe this is just the
beginning not the end of what the
Seahawks are going to be doing I don't
know that Greg Olson falls into the
superstar category at this stage of his
career that Russell Wilson was talking
about before the Pro Bowl but Russell
Wilson has made it clear he wants to see
them add pieces on both sides of the
ball because it's not gonna be easy to
emerge in the NFC it's not gonna be easy
to emerge in the NFC West no it's not
the 49ers in the Rams and the Cardinals
so they've got their work cut out for
him and I like to see them being
aggressive with their their attempt to
try to get back to where they were you
know it was in 2018 that Russell Wilson
told me it felt like 2012 all over again
which means next year you win a Super
Bowl now this year 2019 Pete Carroll
made the reference to 2012 all over
again at some point it's got to be 2013
well then I like the idea that they're
trying to make this year 2030 yeah yeah
I mean you're right Mike they're getting
close right I mean they're there this is
it feels does feel like that because
this two is the other aspect they have a
lot of money to play with for the first
time in the offseason so they can buy
and improve their football team and
we'll be back at pft right after this
well done
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports